joe biden has picked his running mate
after
weeks of speculation we can now say with
certainty
that joe biden's vice presidential
candidate is going to be
california cop kamala harris here is
what kamala had to say about this
wonderful honor
when vice president biden was in the
united states senate
working with segregationists to oppose
busing
which was the vehicle by which we would
integrate america's public schools
had i been in the united states senate
at that time i would have been
completely on the other side of the
aisle
and let's be clear about this had those
segregationists their way
i would not be a member of the united
states senate cory booker would not be a
member of the united states senate and
barack obama would not have been in a
position to
nominate him to the title he now holds
and so on that issue we could not be
more
apart which is that the vice president
has still failed to acknowledge
that it was wrong to take the position
that he took at that time
oh i'm sorry that wasn't kamala
accepting the running mate spot that was
when kamala smeared biden as a
vicious vicious racist during
a presidential debate uh obviously
joe biden probably has no idea that
they've picked kamala harris to be his
running mate because
the democratic party doesn't view people
as people they view them
in slots for divvied up identity groups
well we will hopefully inform the former
vice president as he watches
uh this show today and we will break
down exactly what this means for the
race
what this means for the broader project
of the left i'm michael knowles that's
the michael knowles show
[Music]
man can you imagine how upset joe
biden's going to be when he finds out
that the democrats picked
kamala harris as his running mate he's
going to be furious he'll forget quickly
but he'll be furious for a little bit
my favorite comment from yesterday's
from hudson dean
hudson dean pointed out that according
to cnn it's not looting
it's called undocumented shopping that's
true that's true the blm rioters
they just don't get receipts but there's
no reason to suggest that that's any
different
than than other regular american
shoppers
that's uh that's probably there's no
distinction as far as the left is
concerned
uh we will get to this significant news
the the kamala harris pick first though
i've got to thank our friends over at
expressvpn you know
there's a lot of censorship these days
on social media you might have noticed
maybe you're not seeing this show quite
as often on youtube or elsewhere
uh that's that's just what happens big
tech is
now actively suppressing conservatives
this has a lot to do with the election
but it happens in non-election years too
they the left wants to silence and
remove any voices
they don't disagree with remember
twitter was supposed to be an open
platform
doesn't seem so open anymore instead of
letting social media sites revoke your
right to free speech
how about revoking their right to your
data
now one thing you could do is you could
just deactivate all of your social media
platforms
that just sort of lets them win though
doesn't you don't want to do that
instead i would recommend expressvpn
so you know social media sites make all
their money by by
tracking your searches your video
history everything that you click on and
then selling your valuable data
when you use expressvpn you anonymize
much of your online presence by hiding
your ip address
that makes your activity much more
difficult to trace and sell
to advertisers you got to watch i do not
go online now if i don't have a vpn
installed
i highly recommend you do too it's
finally time to say no
to censorship take back your online
privacy expressvpn.com
michael by visiting my special link you
will get an extra three months of
expressvpn service for free that is
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
michael expressvpn.com michael to
protect
your data today especially now that we
got kamala the cop running as the vp
pick you know she might look it might
happen the entire liberal establishment
is pushing
for the biden harris ticket a lot of
people have tweeted him they've said
what do you think of the harris ticket
does it help biden does it hurt but
my view on it is it was his only choice
i mean i've
assumed that it was going to be kamala
harris for weeks now because biden
backed himself into a corner in the name
of diversity
joe biden said that he was going to pick
a very specific
woman and she's got to be black and so
he really limited
his his scope of people in the
in the name of diversity he limited
himself to to uh i don't know what three
or four people around the country
one name that was floated was susan rice
susan rice was the fall man for benghazi
in the obama administration
and as the durham investigation comes
out into all of the corruption of the
obama admin
probably not a great idea to pick susan
rice so she wasn't going to work
karen bass as we've explained on the
show many times is an actual communist
so karen bass is the head of the
congressional black caucus she's a you
know she's congressman
she's actively supported fidel castro in
her career
that was a little bit radical even for
today's democratic party and so you're
left with
this third choice very flawed choice
extremely unlikable but she's the last
one left because
of the identity politics of the left
you've got kamala harris
who is i guess she's a black woman or
she's a woman of color at least
she ran a terrible presidential campaign
the first thing she did
was hire up all of hillary's people so
hillary 2016 one of the worst
presidential campaigns ever run and then
kamala harris because she is a sort of
just establishment candidate she hires
up all of those people
and she launched a particularly vicious
attack on joe biden
during the primaries that attack was
that he's a racist that he worked with
segregationists
that he he opposed busing busing is not
exactly a popular issue
in 2020 but she launched it she thought
it was her best attack it flopped but i
guess in the end it worked out because
she's going to be
his running mate now and i think the
slogan is going to be racist harris
2020. i don't know how how convincing
that's going to be kamala though is not
the only endorsement
that joe biden got over the past couple
days he also got a very
much more powerful than kamala harris he
got the endorsement of
chyna this according to nancy pelosi
nancy pelosi
uh went on tv she went on cnn to
describe the state of the race
and i don't know why i think she may
have been having a senior moment herself
she admitted what we all know
which is that china america's number one
geopolitical adversary
is rooting for joe biden but the chinese
they what
what the what they said is china would
prefer joe biden whether they do that's
their conclusion that they would prefer
japan
is that a good thing i mean what she's
referring to here is uh bill evannina
who's the director of the national
counterintelligence and security center
he suggested that russia you know is
rooting for president trump
i mean they've been suggesting this
since 2015
but that china and iran
would prefer joe biden and it just shows
you how in their own bubble democrats
are
that that nancy pelosi thinks that
an endorsement from china will help him
because this is what we've been told for
the past 30 years the kind of
liberal establishment with some
republicans and certainly all of the
democrats
have hailed the rise of china they've
encouraged it
they've actively supported it at various
times and the idea
here was that if you rise up china if
you give them a lot of money and you let
them cheat on trade deals and you let
them steal technology
then eventually they're going to be
super duper rich and they're going to
democratize
it's sort of like make china very very
rich
step a step b we don't know
step c they're going to become a
madisonian republic
oh it's that step b it just hasn't
happened it hasn't happened at all and
then china obviously inflicted on us
this
wuhan virus which has shut down the
entire world for the past six months
so there are a lot of problems here
they've taken a lot of american jobs
they've steal a lot of american
technology
they've spied on us a lot of times
they've cheated on trade deals they've
devalued their own currency and they've
done all these sorts of terrible things
but according to the global world order
china is good this is why mike bloomberg
didn't want to criticize china this is
why
three of the four big tech oligarchs
when they testified on capitol hill
didn't want to criticize china only
zuckerberg would even admit that they're
stealing our technology
that view is not a left right thing
that's a
liberal establishment over the entire
world thing
compared to uh we the people you know
compared to common sense people
on both sides of the aisle and on this
divide you know if you kind of shake
yourself out of this
mirror left right republican democrat
divide if you if you see it more as
we the people who want politics versus
the
administrative technocratic elites you
see that
joe biden's campaign is only geared
toward
that kind of administrative state we'll
get to that in one second however
first i've got to thank our friends over
at raycon
you know about rake i've told you about
raycon before haven't i you need a pair
of wireless earbuds that is
mandatory in 2020. if you still have
wires dangling from your ears
it's like you're living in the stone age
you need to get them they make life much
easier
raycon earbuds start at about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market
and they sound just as amazing as the
other top
brands that you know i'm not going to
name names okay i'm not gonna go throw
stones with people but i am gonna say
raycon they sound great they're a
totally fair price they look really good
too their newest model
the everyday e25 earbuds are their best
ones yet with six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
a more compact design that gives you a
nice
noise isolating fit raycon's earbuds are
so comfortable they are perfect for
conference calls they're perfect for
listening to podcasts
especially perfect for listening to the
michael knowles show highly recommend
that
the company was co-founded by ray j and
a bunch of other celebrities
now is the time to get the latest and
greatest from raycon
you can get fifteen percent off your
order right now at buy raycon dot com
slash knowles canada wles
that is by raycon dot com slash knowles
kin wle s
for 15 off raycon wireless earbuds
what's that address
i'll tell you again by raycon dot com
slash
knowles this is the real issue i think
the issue is not one of right versus
left it is
we the people versus the administrative
state the elites who appoint themselves
to govern
this whole country without any real
accountability to the voters
i think that's the big difference here
and we've talked about that before it's
been called the administrative state the
deep state the bureaucracy
the technocracy that is who joe biden is
running for
one thing that was so shocking about the
kamala harris pick
is that she attacked him harder than
anybody else in
the in the democratic primary and she
attacked him in a particularly vicious
way you know there's
there's nothing worse that you can be
called in modern america
than a racist racism it's just become
the term for bad i mean it's
become the term for evil and she went
after him that way so why pick him
it's because the democrats don't look at
individuals
right joe biden is not an individual joe
biden is an empty suit he is the absence
of a candidate
he is not only out the absence of a
candidate in himself because
there's a lot of wind blowing in between
his ears he is also the absence of a
candidate in the campaign he's not
campaigning he's not going out there
they just want someone to be the face of
the bureaucracy
and as far as as that goes kamala harris
fits the description as well
come on what does kamala harris believe
that's going to be the title of my next
brilliant blank book it's going to be
called what kamala harris believes
a comprehensive guide there's not going
to be anything in it
obviously she will switch her opinions
based on public opinion polls
she will lie through her teeth i mean
she wanted to pander on that show the
breakfast club one time
so she talked about how she loved
smoking joints and listening to snoop
dogg when she was in college
years before snoop dogg ever even made
an album it no i'm not i don't know if
she smoked pot or [ __ ] she probably
didn't smoke pot
it's just a thing that she says to
pander she doesn't care
and the same goes for joe biden joe
biden tweeted out yesterday something
that i think typifies his candidacy and
what it means for the democrats
he says i promise you if i'm elected
i won't waste any time getting this
virus under control
i'll call dr fauci and ask him to stay
on
i'll bring together top experts and
leaders from both parties to chart a
path forward
we'll get it done together
if your entire campaign is i'm going to
give all my power to dr fauci
why don't i just elect dr fauci why am i
electing you joe biden
his whole candidacy is i'll get other
people to do stuff i'm joe biden
i'm joe biden you have to elect me so
that i can get other people to do things
first of all dr fauci hasn't been right
about anything i mean dr veggie's been
completely wrong
he's been in that job for what 40 years
now
no one's ever elected him he's just the
face of the bureaucracy
and what joe biden is saying here he
says we'll keep fouchy on
we'll get is what he's saying is we will
return
away from this crazy trump moment where
we the people got a voice all of a
sudden
we will return to rule by the
administrative state
this this project began 100 years ago
with woodrow wilson where woodrow wilson
explicitly says this
he says we want to divorce politics
from administration so it's politics
when you go out there you give a speech
you say we got these issues
and we're going to fight for these
issues and then some other candidate
says we're going to have other issues
and we're going to oppose that other guy
right that's politics then you decide
administration is just carrying out
orders
right you know an administration exists
in every institution so who
decides then what the rule is well
increasingly the rules are being made by
these
headless bureaucrats at these agencies
that have no accountability whatsoever
you know the presidents come and go but
the bureaucrats remain
the same and so the left views this they
say ah yes
finally we get to just plug in
absolutely pointless people to enforce
our agenda that we were going to do
anyway
and what is the name for this well the
washington post is already calling it
historic historic this from jennifer
rubin who is
a democrat she's a democrat writer at
the washington post
who for some reason pretends to be a
republican but she she doesn't support
anything republican support
she doesn't support any republican
candidates and she's in no way a
conservative but
but the fake news is so fake that they
will look you in the they will they will
hire a democrat
have her write democrat columns every
single week and then tell you she's a
conservative
that happens all the time so the
headline for this column
it's been a rotten process but we can
appreciate the milestone
of the first female vp
first female vp because biden's already
won
i guess according to them you know this
headline is assuming that joe biden's
gonna win they're just assuming it
because of course he'll win that's what
we want and that's the science of
history and that's
that's where we've got to go and you
know trump wasn't supposed to win the
first time there was an accident some
glitch in the system
but don't worry we're going to cheat him
out of it this time and
and this time joe biden is going to win
if if they're just talking about the
first female vp candidate first of all
we've had other female vp candidates
before but we had one very recently we
had one in 2008 that was sarah palin you
remember her
do you think the washington post is
publishing columns you know this is a
wonderful milestone it's historic
it's so important it's so wonderful that
she got picked
i don't think so there's nothing
historic about it
joe biden told us months ago he was
going to pick a woman
so what's historic there's no surprise
he didn't even have to write
this column but that's how they view it
you know what was really historic
trump's victory because no one thought
that was going to happen because we were
told 99 chance hillary wins that was
historic
you know what was historic the popular
tea party movement
that was that was a genuinely grassroots
campaign
of completely peaceful protesters who
would show up to a rally site and leave
that rally site cleaner than it was
before they got there
they weren't stealing gucci or nike
sneakers that was historic but for some
reason
that never goes down in the annals of
history and the reason for this is
the left has believed for over a hundred
years that they've discovered the
science of history
they know what's going to happen they
know what progress is so you can only be
on the right side of that the wrong side
of that
when when things contradict their view
of history
now they ignore them you know they said
oh that wasn't supposed to happen but
then they get right back on the track
the mainstream media knows what's going
to happen in the future that's why
they're already running stories on the
future the mainstream media are bracing
for sexist attacks on kamala harris
take a listen ali good to talk to you
about this so
tell us a little bit about these groups
and and what kind of
negative attacks are they bracing for
based on
what we've seen with previous women
politicians and candidates who have run
for
political office you know it's one thing
when the democrats report fake news when
something happens and then the democrats
lie about it or they spin it so
egregiously that you can't
recognize it it's another thing entirely
when the democrats spread fake news
about things that haven't
happened yet they yes
these groups are bracing for sexist we
know they're coming
oh yeah you know what trump is gonna say
oh it's so t you should be impeached for
what he's gonna say
he's do you know what these
right-wingers are they should be
censored on
social media for the things that they
haven't yet said but are going to say
that's it i mean that's the science of
history right they're they're predicting
what's going to happen
meanwhile just a note on sexist attacks
just a note on that previous female vice
presidential candidate for the
republicans
did you ever see these kind of pearl
clutching hand ring
ringing segments about sarah palin
after the awful what you could call
sexist attacks on her
no i don't think so do you think anyone
was predicting oh you're gonna be the
awful attacks on surveillance no
because the same people who are worried
about those attacks on sarah on on
kamala harris were the ones launching
the attacks on sarah palin
so the msnbc feminist reporter i don't
know i don't know what her actual title
is
she gives this report on what's going to
happen
a lot of these women's groups are
looking back at 2016 and seeing the way
that president trump used to
dog whistle all the time about hillary
clinton's gender i remember i used to
hear him
say things like she lacked the strength
and stamina to be president
you're not allowed to say that about
hillary clinton hillary clinton who
famously lacks the strength and stamina
to be president you're not allowed to
say that about her because she's a woman
it doesn't matter if it's true about the
individual she's a woman and so you're
not allowed to say that
and specifically she's a democrat woman
notice implicit in the argument here
they're not asking
does hillary clinton lack strength does
hillary clinton lack stamina
hillary clinton famously passed out as
she was walking to her car during that
campaign
she was always fatigued she admitted
this in an interview she said
i'm chronically fatigued i fall asleep
the second i sit down on airplanes
so it's it's obviously true of her that
she lacked the strength and stamina
but what the left says is we don't care
about the particulars we don't care
about we don't care who's running in
2020.
who's joe biden who cares he's just a
filler he's a filler
for history which will inevitably move
toward
the left and he'll do whatever we want
kamala harris same thing
she said a bunch of stuff she smeared
our top no one cares
no one's voting for either of these
people these people are very unlikable
they're just voting for the left-wing
project broadly
left-wing project broadly by the way
might win
that's the worry because a lot of people
don't want to engage in politics
you know i'm here at this claremont
fellowship and we're talking about the
founding and
and what that means and how it's played
out over the course of american history
and john marini one of the scholars who
made a great point yesterday which is
that increasingly
everything is politicized the nfl is
politicized the mlb is politicized nike
shoes are politicized
everything and our whole culture is
politicized
except for politics except for politics
you you must have a political opinion
about every single thing on earth
but you are not allowed to have a
political opinion about politics because
politics
has been taken away from the people and
given to these
faceless bureaucrats some of them
occasionally pop up and you remember
their name like dr fauci
but they're the ones making our
political decisions for us all the
little alphabet agencies that operate
out of the executive branch but have no
accountability
to it really they're the ones who are
actually ruling us
and in part i think it's why the left
distracts us with a bunch of stupid side
issues
is so that we can all chatter about some
nonsense and not engage in
actual politics which is being done by
the left-wing experts so we've got
the dog whistles that are certainly
going to come
against kamala harris and the only
people hearing these dog whistles are
leftists what does that say about them
it seems to suggest they are the dogs
but regardless of these sexist
attacks i got to say this for president
trump at least he can bring himself to
say the word
woman the same cannot be said of cnn
which recently gave a report on not how
not how pregnant women are reacting to
kovid they coined a new phrase
pregnant people women
are feeling nervous about expanding
their their family or starting a family
because of the pandemic
why that's exactly right anne-marie and
they're worried for two different
reasons
one simply health reason there's so much
that we don't know about
the coronavirus in general and then how
that impacts pregnant people in a unique
way
pregnant people hold up a sec i just
realized that that wasn't even cnn you
expect this step of cnn
that was cbs that was a network news
channel
that was something that a lot of people
watch a lot more people watch that
than watch cnn so so this kind of
language this
taking away sex taking away gender
eliding everything that's
weird double speak this is now infecting
the total mainstream right the actual
networks for cbs that's happening on the
other ones as well
so she coins this term pregnant people
but the thing you have to remember is
this is so unnatural right it's so
unnatural
to deny that biological sex exists it's
perhaps the fundamental fact of our
nature
sex so they say it they get their
talking points they're told
what how to describe gender but then she
slips in the very same segment
she refers then to women you have this
perfect storm of a
public health crisis combined with what
we're
anticipating to be a gigantic economic
crisis
and the result is that a lot of women
and families
are simply saying now is not the right
time to be either starting or expanding
a family
a lot of women and families why use the
phrase woman in one place but not in the
other place
there was another term that was coined
by the media the other day individual
with a cervix there's some media outlet
said
yes i think with cnn it's always cnn in
my mind they're all cnn
in any case they said you know cervical
cancer
specialists are saying that individuals
with a cervix
should get screened for cancer there's a
shorter phrase for individuals with a
cervix
there is a more precise phrase for
people who
get pregnant as women
so even this woman on on this even this
individual with
whatever body parts they that she has
this person
says you know we're talking about women
right because she kind of loses her
train of thought
but what is being pushed and normalized
is this idea
that sex doesn't matter at all and this
is extremely degrading to women i never
want to hear
that trump is demeaning toward women or
sexist against women or misogynistic or
whatever again i don't want to hear it
because there's a song called whap is it
whap or wap
i don't know this is put out here by an
artist named cardi b
i know that ben got in trouble for this
the other day because ben just read the
lyrics
of this disgusting song it's probably
the most disgusting song i've ever heard
this is actual audio pornography which i
didn't know could exist
ben got in trouble for it so you know
obviously we've gotta
get into it here i thought what i didn't
even watch ben's clip
but people were very upset that he was
calling this out so i it made me go and
listen to the song
this thing is so obscenely degrading to
women but that's not just that's not the
only point i have to make about it
if that were it you know look that's rap
music rap music is always degrading to
women
the the point about this is the
degradation of
the individual and the degradation of
american society and the degradation
of our interpersonal relations so the
song begins i'll have to clean this up
as i go i suppose
it opens up with a repeated line there's
some [ __ ] in this house
sung by a woman she's very proud of this
she's accepting her identity
as a [ __ ] she's reveling in that
spit in my mouth look in my eyes saying
you know degrade me i want to be
degraded and i want you to acknowledge
that you are degrading me while you do
it i don't cook
i don't clean but let me tell you how i
got this
ring a a i'm skipping around to just
the lines that i think really tell you
something here beyond the
the language of most of it is so
disgusting i certainly can't read it on
the show
but listen to that i don't cook i don't
clean
but let me tell you how i got this ring
what she's saying is
marriage is transactional no man would
want to marry a woman because he loves
her
because there is something lovable about
her because he wants to give of himself
to her
a man would only marry a woman to get
something
and so what could what could he get well
the traditional model that we're
rejecting
is that you know men marry women so they
can cook and clean for them
but what this enlightened empowered
woman is saying is no i we don't do that
that would be degrading
uh this man uh condescended to marry me
because i do filthy sexual acts on him
all the time
and i allow him to degrade me so that's
and that's why this is much more
empowered
now of course this is a caricature of
what marriage used to be
marriage was not merely a fact of you go
and you hire a woman
to cook and clean for you there's a
little aspect of that but
more it's about giving yourself to the
other person in this union
for life but because of that progressive
misunderstanding of the past which
you know the past has to be awful so
things always have to be worse in the
past
and things we also apply this highly
economic
model of how of interpersonal relations
very selfish model of interpersonal
relations we apply that retroactively in
the past
even as we reject it so she's viewing
the past through that lens
but then because now we're all
enlightened and everything's about sex
she's saying no no
it's much more empowering that i i
conned my husband into marrying me by
performing a lot of strange things on
his body
ask for a car while you ride that
thingy i don't know what i won't use uh
i want to use her language
ask for a car right as in
i'm not doing this to my husband because
i love him he's not doing it to me
because he loves me
this is just transactional but don't
forget we're not taught you know it says
there's some [ __ ] in this house
what what cardi b is saying here
fundamentally is that
the relations between the sexes are
are transactional and and we all women
are [ __ ] i mean that's that's the
point here
is even even with your husband you are
engaging in
something that is no different from
prostitution
uh another line here he bought a phone
just for pictures
of this uh particularly desirable
genitalia again she uses different words
he bought a phone for it so she's kind
of tricked him into spending money to a
third party right to this kind of
capitalist culture some company to turn
me
into a porn actress
so that he can then go away from me
and do whatever he's going to do to
himself
looking at these pictures right it's
it's
you're divorcing you're making it so
transactional that by the end of that
line the woman's not even there anymore
she's not even the one performing the
sex acts
she has become nothing more than a
commodity that you are using
not you know you're not just using her
to get a thrill in person you're using
her to get a thrill in perpetuity
on yourself pay my tuition just to kiss
me
on this desirable genitalia now make it
rain
if you want to see some desirable
genitalia put me through school
don't put me through school to make me
better to you know edify me
so that we can have this wonderful life
together no no it's just a con even
education here
is just about getting something over on
the other person
the way we think of love and education
traditionally is it
makes us better it's a positive good but
not here it's all a zero-sum game
for the left and then this this line oh
my gosh switch my wig
make him feel like he cheating put him
on his knees
give him something to believe in there
it is switch my wig
meaning i'm going to dress up like i'm
not me i'm going to be
somebody else and this is going to
excite
my husband it's going to make him desire
me because my husband is getting tired
of me he's he no longer desires me
this kind of cheap transactional sex has
run its course so now i'm gonna
i'm going to get even more perverse i'm
going to pretend like i'm some other
other woman and that will finally excite
him a little bit more at least for now
and then the key put him on his knees
give him something to believe in
because he he believes in nothing she
believes in nothing none of these people
believe in anything
beyond the satisfaction of their own
selfish appetites and desires
and so she will make an idol out of not
just herself but a very particular part
of herself
and this will finally give him something
to believe in it's an acknowledgment
actually
that man is fundamentally a religious
being it's an acknowledgement that we
want something that is beyond this world
that is beyond the satisfaction of our
selfish desires but we have no outlet
for that we don't know
we don't even know how to talk about
that anymore and so
the nearest we can get is audio
pornography
to to describe a way to trick your
senses into believing that you've
transcended that appetite
and and given given in to something
higher
there was a similar literary analysis
made about this by sukihana i don't know
who that is we'll get to that one second
first though
i gotta thank you i gotta thank you for
going over and subscribing to the
michael show
youtube channel there are many reasons
to head on over to like subscribe and
most importantly share the videos on
that channel
and the main one is youtube's messing
with us they don't want people to see
those videos
so head on over youtube has now
demonetized half
of all of our videos which i don't
really care about because i don't get a
percentage of that money
so i don't you know that's fine by me i
don't care you know ben's not going to
get as much on the view that's fine
but people aren't going to see it people
aren't seeing this kind of stuff they're
they're throttling the show so please
head on over and specifically share that
really helps us out
also let's talk about all access all
access members get to join in all access
live
i did one last night it was great you
know because i've been traveling the
past couple weeks so it's always good to
check in and hang out with the daily
wire members
right now if you join all access you get
two
not one but two leftist years tumblers
with your membership as well as early
exclusive new daily wire products
which you saw last week with our limited
edition collectors baseball bat
that you know sold out before i could
get a copy it was only
available to all access members so sign
up right now head on over to
dailywire.com
knowles you get 20 off all access with
coupon code access
dailywire.com knowles coupon code access
to get 20
off your membership we'll be right back
with a lot more
so after we've just indulged this
literary analysis of
of cardi b whap oh
my gosh it just occurred to me that's
that's the acronym that
that cardi b is talking about for her
particularly desirable genitalia
apparently so that's
that's gross here is some youtuber or
performer i don't know
sukihana talking about what the what the
song means to her
i feel like being like
sexual like i don't see not wrong there
because
baby i got uh three kids and i mean
i got these kids from at the end of the
day
me being a whole like these people say
like
honestly i liberate a lot of a lot of
hoes you feel me when i hear cardi
talk about popping some me and my
is witty like we that liberate us
because it's like you
self-respect this host how y'all got
self-respect
like i don't think y'all got
self-respect like that because first of
all
you supposed to tax these that's
self-respect
you feel me like i just it make me feel
liberated like i love crossing
boundaries
because guess what scare money don't
make no money if you gonna be scared to
get that money you won't be scared to be
yourself
and say that's who i am then you ain't
gonna get that coin like that
you're not gonna get that coin like that
because scared money
don't make no money and human relations
including the most intimate relations
including the one of the deepest desires
of our heart
love for another person is all just
about money making money
as a biological point that woman
sukihana describes
the way that she produced her children
only one of those
actually led to her children that she
describes two activities only one of
them
actually did it so there's some
confusion there there's some confusion
on the broader point
what is our relationship about i think a
lot of people today
view sexual relationships and romantic
relationships
as transactional you do this for me i do
this for you
you know both on sort of dates it's like
tinder culture swipe right like okay i'm
gonna pay for dinner and then you know
whatever we'll see what happens and
shake hands and never see you again but
there's also
you also see this in relationships i
mean even even at a kind of higher level
than this but not much higher
you see people say oh yes i picked my
spouse because she's gonna
she's gonna help me in my career i'm
focused on my career and it's gonna go
this way and i need someone who does
this and therefore
and she'll be good and you know or vice
versa this person's gonna make a lot of
money and then this will help here and
it's all about you prenuptial agreements
same thing it's all about you how you're
going to protect yourself
when this thing eventually breaks off
it's all about you got to make sure
you get yours very different than the
traditional view
you know elisa likes to remind me we're
catholic
there's no there's no out this is it
for life man uh and and there's
something really
healthy salutary about about that
knowledge
that this is about much more than a
transaction and selfish desires that
that there are certain bonds that are
unbreakable but in our consumerist
culture
we don't have that and that's not
actually just the left's fault it's also
the right i mean the right
in its obsession with economics in the
last 30 years
basically selling out their principles
just to make an extra buck on
whatever policy is is popular of the day
you know pretending
that free trade is the great
international unfettered free date
that's the bedrock conservative
principle no of course it's not
politics we want to conserve things we
want to conserve the good free trade can
be wonderful but
but free trade all of these kind of
technocratic
policies that are administered by
bureaucrats they are subordinate to a
real
politics to an authentic politics where
we decide for ourselves
what we want and where we can ideally
live the virtues
which people are not living when they
when they listen to and perform
wap so president trump i think he's
a lot a lot better for women than any of
this kind of stuff and by the way you
just track it too
there have been a number of surveys done
of of happiness so take it with a grain
of salt
but since women's liberation since we
were told that
degrading sexual activities uh actually
empower women
women's happiness has declined
precipitously
both relative to men obviously you know
and in absolute terms it's declined this
idea that women are going to be
empowered and happy
and flourishing uh it hasn't happened
the opposite has happened
but we can't let trump off the hook this
trump made a comment it was
sexist misogynist chauvinist
ist-ist i don't know so terrible the
left is furious
he was asked about the vice presidential
pick and you know kamala harris or
any of these other women he said well
you know biden said he was going to pick
a woman and i think a lot of men
are offended by that take a listen first
of all he roped himself into
uh you know a certain group of people
he said he had to pick a woman he he
said that and you know some people would
say that
men are insulted by that and some people
would say it's fine
i i don't know look some people would
say that okay i'm not saying that but
maybe i could say that if i wanted to
say that
which i haven't done but some people
certainly have
i love the trump's circumlocution to
just get ideas out in the world
he's absolutely right men should be very
offended by what joe biden said
not because he picked a woman running
mate i don't think
she is going to help him in particular
but that's not why it's not the fact
that he picked a woman
it's the fact that he's picking a woman
simply for being a woman
he's picking a black person simply for
being a black person as if to say
i don't care about any of the qualities
that this person has
i just want to check this box and so i'm
going to cut off
half of the population more than half
the population because he said it has to
be a black woman
i'm going to cut off more than half the
population i don't care what the content
of their character is i don't care about
their virtues
because i just want to check this box
the individuals the people don't matter
we're riding this wave of history we're
on the right side of history so you just
have to fill in the slots
uh we were talking to this the same
great scholar john marini
yesterday about this and uh you know
this this problem of the the individual
is a big one i mean this this problem of
not being
it like they don't view the people in
any way as
individuals they just view them as
vessels to uh to you know
advance their agenda martin luther
king's line
i i have a dream that one day my
children will play with white children
and they won't be judged by the color of
their skin they'll be
judged by the content of their character
what mourinho was pointing out is
this that line doesn't make any sense
today it's it's not a meaningful phrase
people don't know what it means because
in order to judge someone on the content
of their character
you have to have an objective standard
by which to judge character and the left
has destroyed that
the way you used to do it is by the
virtues by objective
virtue which you can name and you can
measure and we were all told
but we we no longer share that view of
of mankind
objective virtue has been replaced in in
john marini's words
by subjective values and values are just
preferences you and i we can have
whatever values we want
now it's like yeah i value chocolate ice
cream you value vanilla ice cream i
value
coke you value pepsi i have it right you
can't judge them and so you can't you
can't judge someone on the content of
their character the left doesn't even
want to try they're only judging them
not on metaphysical criteria
but on physical criteria and that's it
that's all
so they've got their dnc speakers right
obviously biden and kamala are going to
speak
we've got bill clinton if he's not you
know in an orange jumpsuit because of
what's come out about the epstein island
he'll be there
somebody tells me he'll get out of it
although i don't know if
this might be finally hillary's last
revenge watch out bill
uh bernie sanders going to speak andrew
cuomo
who has handled coronavirus worse than
any governor in the entire country
andrew cuomo whose policies are
responsible for killing thousands of
senior citizens
he'll be speaking because don't forget
the democrats anointed him before
coronavirus doesn't matter what he does
they it he can do no wrong so for
instance
the democrats are furious at trump for
for uh
you know the way he's handled
coronavirus on every objective measure
cuomo has done worse but
they like cuomo so cuomo cuomo he's
shown leadership
he's going to be who knows he could
could replace joe biden
for all that we know at the convention
but most likely he won't so cuomo is
going to speak
whitmer also terribly uh she's handled
this whole thing terribly she's governor
michigan she'll speak schumer
kerry oh my gosh these people are just
they've been around forever aoc that's
the one kind of
new person who's been anointed as a
leader of the democratic party and then
my favorite speaker at the dnc
john kasich jai you remember that name
john kasich
john kasich is the
formerly republican governor of
ohio his father you might remember his
mailman
john kasich he's taking this principled
stand
principle that he's going to oppose
donald trump principled conservatives
stand he's going to vote for joe biden
and kamala harris the most pro-abortion
ticket in american history
principled stand so what's it really
about kasich was interviewed about this
and kasich defended his decision to
speak at the dnc the way he defended it
shows you
the the big issue of politics here again
it's not just left right
it's this issue of we the people versus
the self-appointed benevolent better
elites
kasich in his own words i think i have a
right to define what it means to be a
conservative
hold up no you don't
you john kasich have less of a right
than anybody in this country probably
including jennifer rubin
to define what it is to be a
conservative because you're a sellout
you're a hack
you don't believe in anything you're not
conservative even if
even if we just judged you by your
policies and nothing else
that pertain to your political career
you're kind of a moderate squishy
republican you don't
have any right to define what it means
to be a conservative just a minor
technical point
here's the substance of his defense
and that means a government when
necessary
uh not opposed to it that what the
conservative movement ought to be
is opportunity for everyone the
republican party ought to be a party
that has a positive message
of lifting everyone but you know aaron
look leaders walk a lonely road
and if you're not prepared to walk a
lonely road and do the things that your
conscience tells you to do
then how do you think about yourself
when you look in the mirror
i mean i'm comfortable with the
decisions i make of course there's blow
back you know republicans are critical
some are praising me democrats are
debating themselves should he be able to
do this
but this is not an unusual place for me
to be i've been
a reformer almost all my life i've been
very independent and i'm a republican
but the republican party has always been
my vehicle
but never my master you have to do what
you think is right in your heart and
i'm comfortable here how many times did
john kasich use the first person
singular pronoun in that defense
compare this no one's picking up on this
but it sums up the whole issue
what principles did john kasich just
allude to
what big political issues what broad
political vision did he allude not none
his references were to himself
well look i look at myself in the mirror
and i'm very comfortable with me and
i've done a good job and people are
criticizing me
and people are praising me and i think
i've done good and i've got this idea
and the republican party is fine but
it's really just about me
me me me i me my all through the night i
me mine
i me mine i me mine
me me me and that's basically
the entire never trump coalition that's
how many are there left like three or
four people
they pretend it's about principles it's
not it's just about
them themselves they can't articulate
they always say trump is
a narcissist these people are much more
narcissistic than trump
at least trump is doing something trump
had that great
meme out the other day said
they're not coming after me they're
coming after you and i just happen to be
in the way that's it that sums it up
he always talks about we the people
hillary clinton in 2016 said
it's about me so you know i'm with her
and he said
uh i'm with you that shift of who the
eye is here and who the object is here
that tells you a lot ronald reagan said
this too he said people have always
called me a great communicator it's not
that i'm i'm the great communicator it's
that i'm communicating great ideas
great ideas from the heart of the
american people
it's about you it's about other people
we the people
that's a big distinction here for the
democrats
they don't care what you want they don't
care what you
are prioritizing they don't want you to
engage in
authentic politics they're going to tell
you what to do
they've got the kind of liberal agenda
they're not even going to really ask
they're just going to enforce it through
the administrative state the deep state
the bureaucracy
and the and the republican candidate
here trump is
saying something else he's saying we're
going to empower you it's going to be
weird it's not going to follow
all the conventions that we've had in in
recent years but we're going to do that
anyway and we're going to crack up this
administrative
bureaucracy those are the choices those
obviously cut across party lines
obviously john kasich is going to speak
at the dnc
but that's a much more important
distinction than republican democrat
or conservative liberal or progress
whatever that is a big distinction are
we going to have politics are we going
to engage in it are we going to empower
people
to to choose things for themselves or
are we not
that's your choice in front of us you've
got empty suit racist
empty suit vp whatever 20 20. that's the
democratic and obviously they'll change
their tune and kamala harris will say
joe biden's the least racist guy in the
world
what they're saying doesn't matter they
are
but they're not obviously they're not
listening to we the people
they are going to push that same agenda
that they always have
and then you got trump and you like him
you'll hate him
you're lukewarm warts and all you've got
trump giving a voice to the people
that's your choice let's see if your
vote will count
in november that's our show i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy bourie
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer
austin stevens assistant director pavel
wadowski
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva production assistant ryan
love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen